-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-
and Academy Award-nominate
actress you know from film
such as "American Hustle,"
"Arrival," and "Vice,"
as well as HBO's limited serie
"Sharp Objects."
She stars in "Hillbilly Elegy,
which is in select theaters no
and currently streaming
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-I begged them to let you
stay here!
-Well, nobody asked you to
I'm not a charity case.
-Why am I here, Mom?
-Feel superior, maybe?
-How can you be
so [bleep] selfish?
Do you even care
what you do to Lindsay?
-J.D., shut up.
-You leave Lindsey out of this
-You did the same thing
to Mamaw.
Mom, you just took
and took from her
until she was practically
bankrupt.
-Yeah, she was a goddamn saint
-All she did was bail you out,
Mom!
-Except when it mattered!
-Did you actually want to be
dead, Mom,
or are you too lazy to try
-J.D., don't!
-Oh, I tried, plenty!
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Amy Adams.
How are you, Amy?
-I'm well,
how are you doing?
-I'm hanging in there.
I know you're back in L.A. now
You just finished shooting
up in Atlanta,
but how has the whole
last nine months been for you?
-It's been different.
Yeah.
It's been okay, but I know
we're all going through it
you know?
-Your daughter is 10 years old
is that right?
-Yeah, she's 10, and she's doing
a great job
on her Zoom school, which took
a second to get used to.
-Be honest, do you think tha
after, like,
over the last nine months,
do you think she likes
her parents more or less?
-Less.
-[ Laughs ]
We appreciate your honesty
-It's true.
I mean, I don't know.
We have a really close
relationship, but it is --
it's strange being at home
with her all day.
I feel like she's gotten
an insight into us
that she didn't have before.
So, in some ways, she's probably
more understanding,
but she probably likes us less
-Yeah.
I wonder, too --
I mean, I feel as though
that's a really good point
that they just see us more
and they realize, "Oh, you are
just human beings, too.
You're not anything special.
We thought when you went off
to the office or something
you were doing something
incredible, and now we can see
that's not really the case
-She asked me, she's like,
"Is this what you do all day
when I'm at school?"
I'm like, "No, no, no, no,
I actually, you know,
put clothes on.
I'm now I'm in pajamas
typically, but --"
-I can't believe you raise
the level of difficulty
and got a new puppy
in the middle of all this.
-We did.
It's actually been a reall
great focus.
Her name's Mochi,
and she's just this
fluffy, white...
just such a cutie.
I did realize that having --
I forgot how much work
a new puppy is,
but it was a good distraction.
-And just --
Now, I'm assuming, again,
because of the time we're living
in, Mochi probably
doesn't see people
other than the three of you?
-Yeah, Mochi, I'm discovering,
has a little, like,
social anxiety,
so she's been seeing
more people of late
and she's not really sure
how to respond to them.
She doesn't understand peopl
other than the three of us
so resocializing her is going to
be really interesting, yeah.
-And you have other dogs
as well,
or is Mochi the only one?
-We have two other dogs,
Sadie and Boo.
And we had another dog tha
passed away last summer, so...
-Gotcha. Are the other dog
taking to Mochi?
Are they helpful influences?
-It took a second.
Boo, like, went on
a hunger strike.
She did not eat
for about four days.
We were getting a little worried
that she was just not happ
about the whole situation.
But they've come around, and now
they're really good friends.
And, like, my husband posted
something on Instagram of them
just, like, canoodling on
the couch for hours.
They, like, hug each other and
chew on each other's face.
-That's all you can ask fo
in the end.
I want to ask about
"Hillbilly Elegy," but I als
want to ask about a film you
finished last year, I believe,
called "Woman in the Window,
which is about
a woman in New York
with severe agoraphobia,
who basically lives in her own
apartment afraid to go outside
It must be strange to know tha
you have finished a thing
from the past that is now
so much about the present.
-I know. I filmed it, like
two years ago, too,
so it was a totally
different time.
And now I'm just --
I'll be curious to see
if people want to, like,
be in that apartment with her,
or if they're like,
it's too real, you know?
Although she has a very nice
town home in this film, so..
I wanted to live there,
actually.
-That is -- yeah,
it's still nice to --
no matter how bad a thing people
are going through on TV,
if they have a nice piece of
real estate in New York,
you can't help but think, "Man
I wish I could switch places."
-Listen, I could quarantin
in that town home, yeah.
No, it's -- it will be
interesting.
I'll be curious to see how
people respond to that
when it comes out, like,
if that creates a feeling
of claustrophobia that
they want to visit?
It will be fun to see.
-Well, it's interesting becaus
you balance it against
the other kinds of things yo
see now, which is people
in close quarters without masks,
which is sort of the opposite.
It might be nice for people to
say "Oh, I like this one."
-Yeah.
-"Because I don't --
Like, I know that whatever
she's going through,
at least she's keeping herself
socially distanced."
-That's true.
I was watching
"The Big Bang Theory,"
and I was like, "Oh, remembe
when we could, like, eat
with friends in our place?
-[ Laughs ]
-All the eating on the show.
-I want to talk to you about
"Hillbilly Elegy."
We're going to take
a quick break,
and we'll be right back
with more from Amy Adams.